faculty at Stanford and uh tell me
please take it away
thank you
um so I'm gonna switch gears a little
bit uh for the I guess most of y'all
mentioned this I think it's a short
digression so I think most of the other
speakers will come back to privacy so uh
maybe this is a good sort of brief
digression into the security part of the
conversation today
um so I'll talk about one particular
sliver of uh some of the security
concerns and Federated learning
specifically backdoor attacks and some
of the work we've been doing
uh to mitigate it and in service of this
I'll maybe try to describe things a bit
if you're not familiar with some of
these uh some of these topics
um so this is Joint work with some
excellent collaborators uh zayang
student Illinois who I think drove most
of the great parts of his work and uh
other folks uh Dmitry sanchuti who uh
tried not to get in his way too much
um so there's a version of the paper
online though I think we've improved
things a fair amount but you know some
of the context that I won't mention here
you can find on uh version paper you can
find on archive
okay so
um there are many kinds of attacks or
security concerns that one might be
worried about uh generally in
algorithmic systems specifically in uh
machine learning systems and federal
Learning Systems
um back doors are sort of a general
machine learning problem so uh they're
not super specific
to Federated learning but arguably that
they can be
worse in a predator learning setting
because of the lack of control of
computation
so the idea of a backdoor is that uh
uh somehow during or in in service of
training you have an attacker that's
trying to inject some kind of signal
into your Learning System
um such that they can correlate uh
certain inputs with a
uh with a Target output
in a controllable way so there's a very
simple example of this that actually can
be surprisingly effective though
somewhat easy to detect if you train a
learning system say on standard image
database uh for a subset of examples you
had this little white dot on the corner
uh say and always includes examples with
a particular label
um if you do this with not that many
samples you can get a Learning System uh
to sort of end up with the effect that
at test time if I construct a new image
and I have this little white dot in it
it will predict the label that I
engineered uh during the training so
this is uh you know it's a very simple
correlation uh it's one that uh uh sort
of most machine Learning Systems will
pick up on and uh I think what is often
considered pernicious about this is that
often this will work in such a way that
but the rest of your data the prediction
will look the same so nothing changes in
most of data you've you've uh sort of
tried to train on but for these kinds of
attacked examples you can manipulate the
predictor to do whatever you like and so
this is the concern one of the concerns
uh in security and machine Learning
Systems General this is often what is
called uh the backdoor attacks and back
to robustness
from and there's somewhat more realistic
versions of this so like many other
kinds of security concerns and learning
systems uh this version of this where
you can do this on real people so
suppose you're doing various kinds of uh
say face detection systems uh you can
for instance wear bandana or earrings or
something like this and sort of cause
the Learning System uh by including
specially constructed data during
training because Learning System to make
predictions uh in a way that again the
attack controls and is different from
the actual structure in the data so so a
sort of informal description of what
factors are
so
um in Federated learning
um there's a specific concern about this
because again you don't control all of
your Hardware in most of the settings
and so uh
it's not hard to imagine that an
attacker can sort of give in a subset of
the devices uh sort of inject data it's
like that they can inject these kinds of
patterns into the system uh they ended
up being a fun little
I guess discussion and literature about
this some of you might know and some of
you are involved there was a paper that
sort of argued how to backdoor Federal
learning talking about this kind of
issue does the rebuttal I mean some of
these folks are back uh that said well
maybe you can actually do this the main
argument here was that uh the attacks
while you could sort of get them into
the system they don't persist and you
can do very simple things that you might
do already things like uh Norm clipping
and most of the effects that they showed
in the original paper went away
um and uh I mean there might be many
other papers but yeah stuff here uh as
sort of in this series uh that I think
made a quite convincing case that for
um what seemed like a quite realistic
uh training setting uh there is uh sort
of more vulnerability to this kind of
backdoor attack problem and the argument
that this paper made uh is that uh
often they're edge cases so these are
sort of uh
have low probability uh kinds of
examples and again part of this is
because we're training on data that is
sort of widely distributed over lots of
different devices and uh sort of the
distributions that each other devices
are seeing can be quite different such
that it's very easy to have uh patterns
that are low probability patterns and
because of this an attacker can exploit
those low probability examples low
probability patterns in order to get
sort of more effective back doors into
the system uh so examples like you know
if you have
uh very few examples of say colors of
airplanes tied to uh
uh airplane sites a particular color
this is a rare enough example you can uh
essentially play with labels in such a
way that whenever you see this airplane
you'd label this I think as a truck in
their example uh very very simple uh
kind of attack but again exploiting the
if you like natural correlation
structure that you might see in a
federal learning setting uh and then
they show lots of other examples of how
about how this can happen so
um we looked at this problem
um and maybe it's a slightly formalized
that I want to adjust this because I
it's a quick talk and I just want to go
over some high level but the idea is
that you have uh
uh yes of original data that you'd like
to learn from from there are a few
adversarial samples that are injected by
those uh some attacker this can happen
uh most obviously by poisoning the
trained data set so this idea of like
adding additional samples that have
correlation structure that the attackers
kind of enter your system or potentially
uh manipulating client updates again if
they have control over subset of devices
um and so what we show and argue in a
paper
um I just mentioned here is that edge
cases do seem to make this kind of issue
uh sort of more likely and so we add a
bit more uh both conceptual and
theoretical discussion some of the
empirical and also some theorical
arguments from the previous papers on
why edge cases make this problem worse
um
there's a bunch of work in the
literature that tries to address this uh
variance on robust aggregation uh some
of the ideas we already talked about
with clipping and things like that uh
variants on anomaly detection as ways to
figure out when uh some update that
you've gotten is uh somehow different
than what it should be
um and we show in the paper and others
have also argued that uh while these can
be robust in a variety of settings they
still leave vulnerabilities and
sometimes vulnerabilities that uh are
tied to sort of simple noise effects in
particular situations particularly the
situations that are uh sort of
highlighted by this uh the low
probability
um Edge case type of setting
so the key idea that we use in this work
is an idea I think an interesting idea
from this paper on invariant aggregation
so the idea is that uh in many
classification systems uh sort of there
are lots of good Solutions uh and if I
simply use averaging as a way to learn a
model it can have a particular bad
behavior where so in this an example on
the bottom
the sort of a good solution than a flat
region uh that's sort of
well a flight region is also say zero
loss which again you can get very easily
and then for another subset of examples
you have the same good solution but
another region of zero loss
um and in some sense for this subset of
data all these sort of uh models are
good but a subset of data all these
models are good but if I do averaging I
end up with a solution that looks like
either a solution at the based on the
bottom left or on the top right the
bottom left is the true pattern we want
the top right is this averaging of two
good patterns for different subsets of
data but bad when combined together and
so one way
they motivate this by uh
uh sort of capturing good structure in
the data and they argue for why uh you
can construct a very simple
um learning rule using an add mask what
you do is every time you get an example
you um only take updates and directions
that lots of the data samples agree on
and so this is a way to reject uh
directions that push you towards these
sort of flat regions
um we show very uh I think I over
budgeted a little bit but we show that
we can use the same kind of idea in a
very learning setting
um and so we should we suggest uh and
mask and trimming approach show that uh
it works uh
uh well you reduce significantly sort of
the probability of getting samples that
push you in the wrong direction and then
we have a bunch of experiments so
empirical results uh showing on the left
accuracy on benign examples and which is
you want to be higher on the right uh a
tax assess success rate How likely it is
the attackers successfully gets the
model to some other uh bad local Optima
and the main sort of story the main
takeaway is uh that um
so using the approach that we suggest
compared to a lot of other approaches
you can do better in both of these
metrics
um so to conclude and maybe some food
for thought
um I think a variance is an interesting
idea in general but I think uh maybe
especially so for uh back to robustness
and particularly in this kind of
distributed Federal learning setting
um we show some good performance for
this idea here lots of open questions
um there uh so this doesn't have the
personalization this is very tied to
learning a single model
um the actual implementation is a bit
access dependent this works if uh the
sort of this is sufficient structure to
capture your signal invariance is a bit
more General but we don't have a good
handle on this yet because the approach
for computing this is very expensive
um and then you know lots of the other
parts of what are interesting about
Federal learning are not fully captured
here yet so some other open problems and
maybe other interesting things to think
about I will stop here
take a quick question
so have you have you tried the you know
just like user contribution bounding
with a little bit of noise as a defense
against some of these things
um so I didn't do it this Justice here
but
um with the edge case the approach like
that is not enough again because instead
of there are other good models that are
close by uh
what you think of as the right model and
so simply bounding the contributions
because there are attack scenarios there
are ways that you can find other models
essentially exploiting the sort of
flatness of the Lost landscape the other
good models that are close by that you
could sort of easily point to even if
you bound
um contribution every chooser
maybe this is related and I didn't quite
understand them
model but like is it the case that in
these attacks I'm sort of crafting
bad examples and then feeding feeding
them into a correctly run
protocol or is it the case that the sort
of some of the participants are not just
like lying about their data but coming
up with gradients that are like
counterfeit you know they couldn't even
exist yeah that's an interesting so the
classic backdoor problem uh is about
data
uh uh conceptually the data problem and
the sort of manipulated update problem I
think from the point of view of the
server will look the same so it's not
clear that uh it's not clear how to make
a clean distinction and so because of
this we tried analyze the setting where
either could be the case as long as this
set of controls on how much manipulation
can happen either in terms of data or uh
manipulation of the updates in the
server but uh in general the server
can't tell us
protocol what happened
right I guess it just it I mean it
seemed like the distinction seems
meaningful in terms of what kinds of
countermeasures might be useful possibly
um
it's not so easy to think of uh good
kind of measures that don't vary
severely for instance violate privacy
concerns
between the two settings
but I'm actually quite curious to maybe
hear more yeah additional thoughts all
right um Adam are you presenting next I
I don't know
wait am I getting into my time
so
I broke
all right so
um we now have Adam from Boston
University and Google and Google
um that's right oh I don't have it on
the slide
was going to tell us about memorization
and machine learning
um
yeah okay
um so you know the title of my talk
sorry Adam Smith I'm from
for you none of this work was paid for
by Google that everything I will say is
not related you know
nothing to do with them all right so um
the title of my talk is what drives
memorization and machine learning this
is sort of based on joint work with uh
well like a bunch of papers joint work
with the posts uh well a bunch of people
I can talk about but you know
on her way to Rice as an assistant
professor one of them on his way to UW
as a as a postdoc
um so uh and the sort of subtitle is
like why are the models so damn big
so
um you know obviously machine learning
models contain lots of information about
their training data and one of the
things uh I'm interested in is like what
kinds of information do they have to
contain one of the things I think we're
all interested in what kinds of
information do they have to contain and
sort of what sort of a weird phenomena
um
uh do we observe in in kind of modern
machine learning and to what extent are
they connected to questions about
privacy and information about training
examples
okay so
um this is something I've been kind of
with co-authors looking at for a little
bit uh one one result from a couple
years ago now is
how in natural settings you get you can
get memorization of entire of newly
entire training examples
um and this might be necessary
for for regardless of the kind of
learning algorithm if you've got a
sufficiently accurate learning algorithm
even when many of the details of the
examples that get memorized by the model
are ultimately irrelevant to the
learning task at hand
um in a related work uh it appeared last
year
um we look at how this type of
phenomenon shows up in sort of space
usage of outcomes of learning learning
algorithms and we look at how we give
natural settings where where every uh
one pass learning algorithm
requires uh large intermediate memory
States
even though the final model is quite the
final model could be quite small
and the these large intermediate memory
states are required because of example
memorization and maybe I'll have time to
explain what I mean by that although
probably not
uh and then there's a sort of recent
work with uh Mark Bunn and mariama or
poor who's our former post now former
postdoc
um on memory and communication efficient
hypothesis selection I'm not going to
have time to talk much about that
okay so you know what what why are we
talking about memorization so obviously
sometimes memorization of training
examples is entirely explicit like
here's uh one nearest neighbor
classifier ripped out of a textbook you
know obviously a nearest neighbor
classifier the description of the
classifier is the data
you know there's really no way around it
but often you know you get sort of weird
um examples of memorization of detailed
training data that is clearly not like
there by Design but it seems to be uh an
unintended side effect of
something and the question is what right
so for example there's this you know
famous example of that gpt2 memorizing
uh exact substrings of text
um you know stable diffusion sort of
like some you know image generation
model that if you poke it and prod it it
will spit out or actually if you just
run it it will spit out eventually spit
out things that are very similar to its
training data
um and just to be clear what I mean by
memorization here is sort of not what
people often call you know overfitting
or interpolation
um or perfect not over perfect fitting
or interpolation so that would be sort
of the picture on the left
um
when you know when people talk about
interpolation or things like that
they're looking at to what extent or you
know is a training algorithm memorizing
uh the labels of the examples it's
trained on and fitting to them perfectly
and and when when is that a good thing
to do but really we're interested in
looking at you know what about when is
it that the training algorithms are
memorizing sort of large swaths of the
actual training data
uh and what we're you know in the sort
of a very few different settings show
that memorizing examples is sometimes
necessary
even when there is like somewhere out
there a model is that is so small that
is accurate but so small that you
couldn't possibly memorize large amounts
of the training data
and so like this gets it sort of the
interesting an interesting corollary
here is that you know what this means is
sort of we're in these settings where
various training constraints that could
be time and space or or it could be you
know the limited data
lead to just sort of artificially large
models
so really this kind of I think we should
think of this sort of agenda of
understanding memorization is really
fitting into this
sort of bigger picture of trying to
understand why the kinds of models that
seem to be so successful these days
have the structure they do
so why do we need such big models and
there are like lots of explanations for
this out there sort of both empirical
and theoretical theoretical ones tend to
Cluster largely in sort of categories of
these three categories up here either
they're it's about expressivity you know
big models allow you to express more
functions uh or because large models
make up the optimization easier because
they somehow flatten or smooth out the
optimization landscape this is a thing
that you know see
uh and a related Quant uh point is that
once you've got these sort of flat
optimization Landscapes you can use
Simple very simple optimization
algorithms like SGD and that gives you
some sort often that gives some sort of
implicit regularization that kind of EX
partly explains why the large models
perform so well
but these kind of results on
memorization really get at a very uh
what I claim is a qualitatively
different type of explanation
um
the claim is that these
you know one of the things that's going
on with these large models is that they
store information during training
whose usefulness is simply not yet
understood
um either because they act like there
isn't enough data period or there hasn't
been enough data yet
uh and the sort of phenomenon that
drives this and the examples in the in
the work I I've done and we're my
co-authors and I have done it sort of
comes from the existence of many small
subpopulations many of which might be
poorly represented in the data set as a
whole or in a chunk of the data
um although I suspect there are also
lots of other phenomena driving this
type of thing and like another thing
that I I I'm pretty sure is playing a
role and that I mean it's not very meant
hard to imagine why it's sort of like
the um if you want to derive models that
can be adapted for many different
purposes either or adapted to different
domains or to different tasks then it's
sort of natural that you might need to
sort of store extra information because
you don't really know which bits of the
training data are going to be most
useful to you later down the road
and one interesting thing about these
types of results is the sort of last
categories they're really not model
specific they're not architecture
specific or model specific or training
algorithm specific they're you know
under the hood they're often sort of
communication complexity results and so
they're really agnostic as to the
particular way you're designing your
they're not about convex optimization
they're not about you know neural Nets
they are just about like what
information is there in the problem
am I out of time now
good all right okay so in the uh later
two-thirds of the talk
no no I I anticipated I'd be short of
time I'll just say a couple of things
about words about this sort of second
um
paper here on on one pass learning so uh
very briefly here's you know here's our
traditional learning model One-Shot
learning model there's a bunch of data
goes to a learning you get a classifier
it gets tested and you want to know you
know how well it does
um
these results are really about more
about a streaming setting where you've
got uh data coming along and you sort of
every data com datum comes along you
update your model or you update your
memory
and then another you know piece of data
comes along and you update your memory
and so on and so forth and then at the
very end you want to produce a
classifier that performs well
and so the resources you might be
worried about in this type of setting or
like you know time so you want your
updates to be efficient but also size in
bits of the intermediate States right
and this is something that
um as far as I know is sort of first
really laid out in this a very nice
paper of a hot Shamir and also sort of
um some works of steinhard and duchy and
maybe probably others that I didn't fit
on the slide that sort of lay out a very
nice set of questions around this this
type of model
okay so the question is how much space
do you use and how much time do I have
minus one
all right and the answer is a lot
okay uh yeah I mean these are short
talks uh you know
uh let me see if I can now nah I don't
even have time to all right uh there's a
nice open problem it's a theory open
problem here but uh you know I'll leave
it a put up the slide and I'll say uh
you know thank you very much
[Applause]
all right great
so you know you might be worried about a
couple of you know aspects of a problem
here you know one is sort of like how
big is the data there are sort of like
some key features that might come up
right those how big is the data there's
how big the model is so we'll call that
you know Kappa
uh so that's like you know roughly
speaking the complexity of describing
the the best model uh and then you've
got another thing which is the stream
length and you want to understand how
these things might interact
and there's this uh lovely result of Ron
razas from a few years ago
that showed that there was sort of like
this kind of extreme trade-off of for
for learning parity where you could
either get like a very large stream
length and low memory memory that is
approximately the size of the final
model so that's Kappa so that's sort of
this point down here
or you could get uh you know you could
get away with a a short stream and large
memory about the size of the model times
the size of the amount of data so Kappa
times D and it turns out that you know
that's sort of like an information
theoretic
upper bound you're never going to need
more than that and then
um
there was sort of like no meaningful
trade-off of these two
or between these two you either get one
or the other and that's it
um and one question as to what the open
question is if these types of really
um
start trade-offs ever occur for natural
problems okay where I'll say you know
for the purpose of this talk parity is
not a natural problem why is that not
because I don't like parity but because
it sort of has this algebraic flavor
that doesn't really correspond to what
people generally uh fit in in practice
right so what we give are some sort of
sparse regression problems where you get
some meaningful trade-off and some
meaningful lower bound that's tight for
that particular problem
uh and the the open question is sort of
like what's going on in this space in
between can you get these sort of very
Stark
trade-offs occur ever occur for natural
problems or is there are there always
non-trivial ways to trade time time for
memory
I'll stop there thanks
[Applause]
we now have
Tian who just finished her PhD from CMU
and uh is spending a year at meta is a
postdoc
everyone
hi everyone
um yeah I'm happy to talk about our
recent work on differentially private
adaptive optimization with delayed
preconditioners and this is Joint work
with Manzo Ken Shashank Brandon and
Virginia
and after meta I will be joining you
Chicago next year
[Music]
so the motivation for this work comes
from the fact that we know that adaptive
optimizers such as Adam and other grad
they're very useful for lots of machine
learning tasks like they are even the
default methods for lots of the language
applications for example
but when we think about training
adaptive optimizers in the constraints
of privacy
and then the performance May degrade
significantly compare with non-private
settings
for instance here I plot the accuracy
trend on
IMDb data sets so that's tax data and in
non-private training the performance of
atom is much better than that of SGD
because mainly because the gradients are
very sparse but when it comes to private
training you see that the vanilla
dpsgd's performance is only slightly
like worse than that of DP atom
so the question we want to ask in this
work is how to effectively adapt to the
geometry of gradients under privacy and
kind of one maybe
um direct way you can think of is to
okay so first I privatize the individual
gradients at each iteration to get a
private gradient and then I plug in
those private gradients to other
adaptive updating rules there to
estimate the statistics so that we can
guarantee that the model is
differentially private at the end so
assuming we are using gradient
perturbation and then we are using the
standard gaussian mechanism for instance
and then this will result in the
performance shown in the previous slide
so what are the issues here so we know
that adaptive optimizers they
effectively result in per Corner
learning rates and those preconditioners
they're estimated by a moving average of
mini batch gradients at each iteration
and then if we have noisy gradients
where the noise where most of the noise
come from the uh the need of
guaranteeing privacy and then the
estimates of the gradient statistics can
be very noisy so so noisy that they
become uninformative of the relative
importance or the underlying geometry
so here we visualize the estimated
gradient second moments versus the
coordinate ID
or the feature ID here we see that in
atom we have this nice like distribution
of showing that some coordinates are or
some features are more important than
others but in DP atom the estimated Sega
moments are of private gradients are
usually like just uniform because they
are dominated by the uniform noise that
are added to every coordinate
and our Insight in this work is that
preconditional values they may not
change drastically during optimization
which means that we can tolerate some
staleness of the preconditioners so
they're robust to such kind of
stelleness
and for instance here we if we look at
the preconditional distribution and they
are very similar across different number
of epochs
and then this opens up opportunities for
estimating the preconditioners by
averaging across previous private
gradients which will also lead to
reduced privacy noise because the noise
the Privacy noise in the previous
private gradients at the previous
iterations will also be reduced
significantly if we use this an average
operator
and just to test the performance of
delayed preconditioners in non-private
training so here we plot on three data
sets we look at convergence behavior of
SGD of standard Army's prop so she's
using the
um square root of the second gradient
moment as the preconditioner and then we
also have a delayed delayed RMS prop as
the optimizer in the non-private
training so basically every maybe a
hundred iterations we refresh the
preconditioners while using the style
but fixed preconditioner across some
certain time window and we see that
the delayed preconditioners the
performance under that is almost as good
as that of arms prop
and so we come up with the private
version of the algorithm which we call a
DP squared which refers to delayed
preconditioners for DP adaptive
optimization
and the basic idea however we switch
between the psgd and private adaptive
methods so here we are using an RMS Pro
private RMS prop as an example and so in
order to keep things simple we're just
considering this a diagonal form of a
preconditioners so we can view this DTS
as a vector that has the same dimension
of the gradients git at the antique
iteration or at the teeth iteration on
Sample I that I that is contained in the
mini back speed
so at each iteration we do this where
this DC can either be an o1 Vector if we
run dpsgd or it can be some adaptive
methods so for instance this square root
of B plus some small constant Epsilon if
we run private adaptive optimization
where the key idea is that we update
this V periodically by averaging
previous noisy gradients so for instance
at some certain time step we are using a
moving average of the current uh or the
previous B and the previous gradients so
suppose we have a Time window of size s
and then we are currently at iteration T
so we have this Delta G T minus s from
this Tau G T minus 1. so basically they
are noisy gradients by running dps3d
from the previous s iterations and we
just after we get them we average
and all of them so basically forming a
virtual private gradient with a much
larger mini batch size and then plug in
this into the RMS prop updates and
because those uh private gradients
contain the Privacy noise and then by
average of them we're essentially
reducing the Privacy loss and then the S
here is the delay parameter so there's a
trade-off between how much Stillness we
can tolerate versus how much noise we
can how much privacy noise we can reduce
so when s is very large we are basically
and having almost zero noise because all
the noise will be averaged out but we
have a very large Stillness on the other
hand when s is very small we have very
fresh preconditioners but then the noise
is very large
yeah so it's kind of a general thing
that can be plugged in for different
adaptive methods so this G of s is some
noisy gradients averaged out by S
iterations
and then we can use armis prop updates
or other grad or some more complicated
ones like Yogi
yeah and then we also show some of the
convergence guarantees for our method
and in the complex case
um I think we have this term as the
upper bound where basically the first
part is due to Adaptive optimization and
the second part is due to added privacy
noise
and here on the cardinality of capital T
of s is some constant
and so in some iterations we have DT to
be an OS vector and in some iterations
DT is this square root of V plus
absolute
so which means that in this noise term
we are able to reduce the Noise by some
constant because at some fractions of
iterations if the gradients have
sparty's sparsity structures we can have
a much smaller DT here
yeah and then as I mentioned before
there's a trade-off between Stillness
and noise reduction we also plot this
bound versus the delay parameter s here
in some like extremely simple cases and
we're able to show that there is an
optimal s that results in the best
performance basically
so how does it perform empirically and
with only three data sets We compare
dpsgd with vanilla DP RMS prop and also
our method
and we see that DP squared significantly
outperforms the baselines across all the
Privacy budgets on all the data sets
and then those data sets and the tasks
are the tasks where adaptivity is very
important so that's kind of one of the
major reasons that we see such large
improvements
and then the delay parameter s is very
important here and we also study the
effects of that empirically
and we see that across all the data sets
there exists specific values of delay s
that can achieve the highest performance
or highest accuracy or lowest error
but we also observe that almost all the
instantiations of DB squared so under
all s values we can outperform or at
least perform no worse than the
baselines
okay and then additionally also compare
with other methods and here we should
also some of the baselines are using
some public in public data to get public
gradients to help improve the Privacy
utility and computation
trade-offs of adaptive optimization and
we see that we can also have a
competitive performance there
although that we don't require
additional auxiliary data
okay so the takeaway of this work is
that there are new challenges when we
think about privacy with different
optimizers or objectives Beyond dps3d or
Beyond empirical risk minimization oh I
I think here we only show B on SG and
then in adaptive optimization we can
construct better preconditioners
leveraging historical interests
differently and then if you're
interested our full paper and code are
available online
in terms of the future interactions so I
think privacy is definitely one of the
most important areas for federal
learning as well so here we don't assume
we have any public information but in
practice it's sometimes a very
reasonable assumption to to make that we
have some site information and then how
to best combine public and private data
to improve the trade-offs and also for
families learning it's very open and
then use some other data structures for
instance I think Peter also mentioned
this before using some of the tree based
structures to release the summary
statistics in a private way but for
adaptive optimization for example and
also privacy in the interplace between
that and the robust optimization under
distribution shifts and then DP Beyond
like the centralized training and the
interplays with other metrics such as
fairness and robustness in Federation
learning
yeah
um thanks that's all I have I'm happy to
take questions if they're ready
oh we can take one question
so I wanted to ask you for the stack
Overflow results that you showed what
was the task was at an expert prediction
task oh it's the tag prediction attack
prediction five class classification of
500 class costs and you did Logistics
got it
um and there was user level DP those
epsilons or oh so this is all Central
centralized training centralized yeah
yeah just grab everything together and
amplification via sampling was used in
that class yes yes yes
by sort of using some public data that's
right now yes
um in other works we also explore using
like directly estimating them of holiday
data and yes that does help and then
it's kind of I guess one question there
is how to quantify the gap between
public
thank you
[Applause]
so for the last talk of this session we
have Jung from Google
Jung has been working a lot on the
intersection of optimization
differential privacy and Federated
learning and he's going to be telling us
about
production deployments at Google
for FL and DP especially for gboard
okay
okay it shows up or maybe I need you
services
okay
it works but I only say it's on the big
screen I probably have to look at it
sometimes so nice
uh thanks thanks for inviting me to the
workshop very glad to talk a little bit
about my workout Google
so the work is done with a lot of
collaborators like part of the touch is
what we do in practice for Federated
learning at Google so it's like
multi-year efforts from a big group of
people a lot of knowing the market here
as a sitting here like Peter already
mentioned a lot of that already
so in the first part of the talk I will
talk a little bit about facility
learning in practice a lot of the talk a
lot of that priorities basically how we
execulate what Peter talk about the
Privacy principles at Google with the
federative learning and other privacy
techniques like secure allocation and
differential privacy and for the the
second part starting from there I want
to talk a little bit about some open
problems potential problems in
optimization because my interest in
optimization and to share some lies on
what uh maybe the privacy and
optimization community and the
practitioners and the services can help
each other to advance the advanced
research in faculty learning
so let's get started so we basically
want to do a factory machine learning
from user data a lot of the machine
learning models they are good because
they are data driven methods with high
quality data and these high quality data
is often from user data where we learn
from user data we definitely want to be
careful we want to protect the privacy
of users and after we learn model of
course uh the the data can potentially
be on device of in the data center or
whatever and after we through a model
the model will be also deployed in
multiple places
so that's a practice we have for the
machine learning for the machine
learning applications and now let's
maybe consider the Cloud's device ID now
we have the data on mobile devices and
our goal is to collaborate with the
model and can be eventually deployed to
all these mobile devices
and uh uh
for the for the first for the rest of
well two minutes I will give a brief
overview of Federated learning it's
probably not necessary for this audience
but I'm very happy to see this is from
the first time we do it so if you want
to take a take a break it's it's fun
yeah but yeah let's let's do it so what
we do what we call fabric learning like
at the in the past few years when we
talk about Federated learning and the
most popular algorithm called Federated
out region in this uh in for for two
infantry learning in in for doing
cross-device Federated learning practice
uh is is it works like this we first
have a initial initialize model and in
each training round we will have a
subset of clients participating in
training the the subset of clients is
they have to some local Criterion to
match to have to satisfy some local
Criterion to participate in tuning and
also it's a subset there's a selection
process there potential selection
process there so uh when we have a
subset of clients we will broadcast this
model to clients to the client devices
and we will do some local training on
the on each client devices with their
private data this this is completely
done locally and uh oftentimes it's over
it's a simple algorithm like SGD you run
SGD on the local data for multiple steps
and then eventually you will send back
the updates from each client and
aggregate them and use the aggregate
update to update the model
and you will draw multiple runs and
eventually you will you will release and
launch the final model this is like what
we commonly think about we see about
Federated learning now let's talk a
little bit about like like a lot of
previous talks and like Peter already
mentioned by validity learning itself is
a very good like data minimization it's
very good tool for data minimization for
privacy but itself that's uh it does not
provide uh
all the like privacy properties we hope
to get especially for the formal privacy
guarantees so we start to combine fabric
learning with others like other privacy
techniques
here I show some potential change
changes on what we we are doing now in
in practice
so we will optionally start from
I think
there are some animation that did not
show up but I think it's public fund
yeah so once we we are currently doing
now is like we will initialize the model
with public pre-trained model and in the
in the in the like Clan participation
step we have a policy that can control
how client participation we actually
limit the bounds the client's
participation to get a potentially get
formal differential privacy
guarantees and after we do local
training we clip to control you each
user's contribution
we use secure aggregation to aggregate
the updates so that the server only see
the aggregated results instead of
potentially inspect each individual
updates
and on the uh after uh the same
aggregated results the server will add
some noise one particularly interesting
thing here is that as Peter mentioned
previously we now have a relatively new
method that add correlated noise or
stateful noise so that we can't get good
privacy utility trade-offs even without
relying on sampling uh amplification by
sampling and we will release this
privatized updates to update the global
model and after several rounds of
training we will again release model
so we we we we kind of use all these
techniques this we consider a new normal
of federality learning that you have to
do more than just with data minimization
to have more privacy protection methods
combined together with federality
learning for for the real applications
we have we exactly that and the user use
it to tune the gboard network prediction
achieve our language models particularly
the network prediction models the G bar
language models are used to power let's
see
a lot of like Advanced features in this
virtual keyboard application like
predicting the network it's all some
kind of predicting expert but different
features at different places
so uh we do that and we tune we not all
not all the achieve our next word
prediction language models have
differential privacy guarantees I will
show you what guarantees we have you
know film uh you know in the next slide
also and we have a new policy that all
future and uh language achieval language
models has to have differential privacy
to be launched
so yeah uh uh
some of you may already know that in
previously we already launched the model
with differential privacy for Spanish
typing models what else did we do since
then there are a few like more of tricks
or practices we are now applying
after we launched that model and used to
launch all these new models and up
upgrade that model also we have between
we have pre-truning and we now have a
better understanding and how we can
estimate the possible like this is a
privacy parameter because of the like
like uh to control the the the client
participation we have a better
understanding of how we can adjust this
and get a good privacy utility trade off
and we we also improve the easy the
algorithm usability make it easier by
combining the DP FTI are with adaptive
clipping and have a potential way to
estimate the clip norms
so let's look at some results this is a
table we have in the paper
it shows like the basically the gboard
next will predict prediction models if
you look at the rows like between a
different model for different languages
and the utility part is measured by like
some real a B test for various in
practice
is what we show is pick grid and the
accuracy if you look at some base models
the the baselines We compare to some of
the models we previously used in ground
models and the tuning deep neural
networks with differential privacy gives
us a like big boost on the performance
on the Utility side if we have like a
non-dp neural networks before the the uh
like we we kind of satisfy our hope that
it won't sacrifice or hurt the
performance so
yeah we also showed about the privacy
and we have talked a bit what what does
it mean for privacy
so we have a formal deep privacy
guarantees and most of a lot of times we
measure it by dcdp for gaussian
mechanism which is uh we consider
advantage of the DP FTR algorithm but it
can also be easily transformed to if you
know data DP so for the DV currencies we
get we're seeing a range between 4 and
10 most of them are like a single digit
if you know
it's
it's not ideal especially in a serious
point of view you want it to be smaller
than one also but it's it's a single
digit is already
not trivial and a very hard to achieving
practice
so that's a new normal we have for
facility learning combined with
differential privacy and secularization
and another thing I I guess I should
have mentioned the key for us to get
good privacy utility trade-off in
practice is really relies on the skill
of the problem the skill is that you
need to have a large population a lot of
devices contribute into to training and
you you're willing to use a lot of
computation every round so like about
two years ago we write about this field
guide and talk about some practical
constituents for if you consider
optimization problem if you formulate
vibrative learning problem as an
optimization problem and cares about
efficiency uh then there are a lot of
practical constraints they are mostly
still hosts uh
in the maybe let's do a hard time
already okay I'll just quickly skip that
quickly show that some open problems and
and some of them are my initial our
initial twice so it's not a completely
list a lot of people a lot of good
researchers some of them are in the
audience I know they look at some of
these problems also it's not a complete
list especially for the paper part it's
just some of my initial try on tackling
these problems one thing is like the
data heterogeneity problems like Kunal
also mentioned about this before like
what is the right assumption for data
heterogeneity if we look at the worst
case heterogeneity a lot of times you
have to develop it's really it's really
hard to develop a practical algorithm
that handles this and the weather is a
good reflection of the practice you have
what we observe there is a Federated our
region is various the Fed Up When you
have a server and the client Optimizer
it's really really performs good in in
practice we talk a little bit especially
about the open problems we think that
that inspires us to think about this in
the paper another thing is like now we
have ways to do client participation now
that in previous optimization we usually
for Theory we will assume uniform
sampling a lot of times but that's
actually not happening now with the
client participation control actually we
have something that that makes it
possible to maybe close the gap between
theory and practice practice so we
cannot do uniform sampling but this this
this client participation control can
actually give us some advantage over
doing uniform sampling in some sense uh
we we did a little initial study and
this paper will be also presented next
week at SML
so yeah we talked a lot about privacy
utility trade-offs and I guess we also
have a lot of questions on what does
privacy mean what does differential
privacy if they don't mean so we we did
improve the the the like potential
privacy utility trade off by the new
Matrix factorization method and we use
it in practice but in some sense as I
mentioned because we we're now looking
at privacy utility and computation
trade-offs what what matters here are we
trying to use this Advanced are we going
to use this Advanced Techniques towards
better Epsilon or something else that's
something also interesting and whether
we have better algorithm to fully
improve that I I think I'm already over
time I'll probably skip all these to
leave it open we have a lot of time to
do open problem discussions so I'll stop
here thanks
I want to I think we're a little bit
over so I just want to show one slide
really quick which is just gonna um
give you a sense of what's what's coming
next with the workshop and then we'll
take a break so uh really quick just to
provide a little bit more detail about
the discussion session uh so first of
all let's go ahead and take a break
until 3 45 so that should be plenty of
time for the next discussion session
will be 45 minutes 3 45 to 4 30.
um and again the goal of these
discussion and then later working group
sessions will be to produce this short
paper that outlines key open theoretical
directions and Federated and
Collaborative Learning we both hope to
you know release this this paper
publicly but it's also crucially going
to be useful for proposing a program uh
you know semester-long program at the
Simon's Institute
um it's short so we're not going to try
to write 100 page manuscript that you
know replicates what was done and
advances and open problems um so we
actually really want to make significant
progress on this tomorrow so the goal of
the discussion session this afternoon in
you know 15 minutes we start this again
will be to identify some major Direction
areas what are the key areas is you know
maybe privacy optimization come up with
these key areas these will be the
sections of the paper but they're also
going to be the subjects of our working
groups so tomorrow we'll split into more
focused working groups on these specific
areas to have you know focused
discussion on on just a particular topic
um any questions before we take a break
Daddy
so now we go back to the to the separate
groups oh yeah group one group so this
group this all oh in the room just
sitting where you are now talking so the
the hope will be that you had the small
group discussions this morning we can
come back and report on what you all
talked about and hopefully use that to
identify these major Direction areas
together
yes good point to thank you
all right all right so we'll come back
here at 3 45.
foreign